what do you want Forrest you divorced me
for your television show you were very
largely responsible for killing my
father in outer space you slept with me
with a drug-resistant form of gonorrhea
you showed me a photo of your engorged
deformed penis I don't think that
belongs on this list you have vanished
for months at a time without telling us
where you were you got charged with
[Music]
listen listen am i curious about what
reviews Forrest MacNeil would do in the
future of course it was me I wouldn't do
it well it isn't you and I do whatever
is asked to me no matter what that is no
I don't even understand this I mean
would anybody even do this to me I'll
make an appointment
[Music]
there's a 10% chance that I won't see
you again I hope you feel that I've been
as good a boss
[Music]
first what are you doing should be a fun
one right
[Music]